those case numbers are what has prompted
the cdc to recommend
everyone wear a mask indoors regardless
of vaccination status
nevada leaders now bring in the state
mandate to meet those guidelines that
kicks in friday
madison kimbrough heard from locals and
parents in ccsd about the changes
madison
yeah on friday the new mask mandate will
go into effect all across nevada and
today ccsd announced that when school
opens reopens on august 9
teachers students and staff will all be
required to wear face coverings too
i'm ok with that i think that we should
go back to wear a mask i never took it
off
i think it sucks because since the
mandate got lifted we've been coming to
the store
no mask a heated topic at the forefront
as governor sysolak announced tuesday
that all nevadans are now required to
wear face coverings indoors
even if fully vaccinated mixed reaction
from people across
town but mostly positive as many think
the removal of the mask mandate
was done too soon i feel like i just
want to be safe and i feel like
i'm safer with it on getting dressed in
the morning like me picking out my
clothes i'm picking out my mask
on the flip side many clark county
school district parents feel frustrated
that their children are required to mask
up when school starts on august 9.
i just want my son to go to school
without wearing a mask
i'm his parent and i have the choice
whether i want to send him masks or not
to me having a child sit there for six
hours a day with a mask on is just
not okay but mother of six anna marie
binder feels differently
she says if this is what it takes to get
her kids back in school
so be it for people like me that have
been following along closely
this wasn't a surprise we actually
wanted it there's a lot of parents that
i don't think have really looked their
kids in the eyes and ask them
you know their preference or what they
want
again the new mask mandate in nevada
takes effect this friday and as for ccsd
students and staff are required to wear
face coverings on buses
too reporting live madison kimbrough 8
news now